pauli tor durch forschung
meine fresse und ich keine ahnung warum
man diesen stand einmal einmal diese
abseitsfalle von zusätzlichen kalorien
wie sich bewegen so lange nicht
ca
die bahn hatte verspielte gibt's einfach
franken
b
jdo
was soll das zeit zu feiern
ich habe den auftrag von der green wave
gmbh bekommen dass ich hat die miete für
diesen monat
und wenn ich erst mal den klassenpartner
irakkriege alex es ist vier uhr
nachmittags
und wenn wir nicht voran machen werden
wir niemals fertig hast du die
unterlagen für green wave kopiert
ich habe das ganze wochenende gearbeitet
und gelernt
aber wenigstens hat mich das von mark
abgelenkt seit unserem streiter dass ich
nicht mal bei mir gemeldet
aber weißt du was irgendwie ist mir das
egal
ich muss die ganze zeit an jonas denken
solche deswegen ein schlechtes gewissen
haben sag mal was ist eigentlich mit dir
und reese habt ihr euch gestritten aber
ihr passt doch so gut zusammen
glaubst du nicht das wenn du wieder hier
ist alles gut wird
aber lena show nehmen dich vor jonas in
acht ein freund was soll das denn
was ist los wirst du sauer irgendjemand
würde mich ärgern
meinst du willst vincent du hättest mir
ruhig vorhersagen können dass er so
schwierig ist das mit finster tut mir
echt leid aber weißt du er hat momentan
nicht einfach
seine frau ist aufgehoben und an ihn und
die tochter einfach allein gelassen das
macht den ziemlich zu schaffen
der laden läuft auch nicht gut
also gut dann ist morgen
gestern was aber voll aber an einen
anderen tag nicht
und das trotz dieser wunderbaren neuen
bedienung
ich war gerade auf dem weg zum arzt sah
dachte ich komm mal vorbei das ist schön
normal meine staub allergie ich habe
dort für morgen abend eingeladen
ich koche zwar schön ist und man lernt
ihn endlich mal kennt cool ich freue
mich